[Musique]
J'ai été autorisé à vous offrir une
promotion demikhov dans la nouvelle
sûreté de l'État, vous aurez une belle vie si
vous faites ce qu'on vous dit qu'il y a eu un
terrible accident
Alexis fils a été heurté par un train train
je devais le dire  son fils est mort d'un
accident tragique mon fils et tu ne sais pas que le
meurtre est strictement une maladie capitaliste
c'était un mensonge mon garçon a été assassiné tu
dois te taire
il n'y a pas d'importance dans ce pays il
n'y a pas de non que tu comprennes leur
premier  chose avec raison vous savez ce que les
gens obtiennent ici quand ils ne
veulent pas la vérité ils obtiennent la terreur
se font tuer il est toujours là-bas je
dois le brûler
allez
je pensais que vous voudriez savoir qu'il y en a
un autre dans le besoin URL pourquoi
ces enfants si importants ne sont plus
il n'arrêtera pas de tuer comment allez-vous le
traduire en justice juste
vous deux quelqu'un d'autre ou un autre enfant
pourrait plus mourir je l'arrêterai
tous les enfants de 9 à 14 ans 43 tu sais 44
mon petit-fils était fou  aussi
[Musique]